allow me to introduce you to itana she's
an Instagram model from Barcelona who's
been going viral but she's also just
like totally chilling down to earth
she's into fitness and video games and
yeah if you're wondering she does have
additional photos on her subscription
tier which brings in about 10 grand per
month before you sign up though there's
one thing I need to disclose and it
really shouldn't matter unless you're
some kind of bigot technophobic Nazi but
she's not a biological female she is a
woman but entirely artificial it is
November 29th 2023 and you're watching
the code report by the end of this video
you'll know how to build your own arm of
AI
influencers entirely for free using open
source generative image models like
stable diffusion XL and checkpoints like
Juggernaut that can produce highly
realistic images the first generative
adversarial networks appeared about 10
years ago and at first could only
produce tiny images that you could
barely make out but now anyone can
produce high resolution realistic images
good enough to trick sad lonely men into
buying the NSFW content it's extremely
sad and depressing that the agency
behind this thing is making a six-figure
income especially during the sacred
month of no not November content like
this is rotting the brains of billions
of men around the world although they
are doing a 50% off sale right now so it
does look like a pretty good value
actually luckily 95% of this channel is
comprised of high value alpha males
which means we don't need to consume
content like that instead we reverse
engineer it so we can exploit it for a
financial gain there are many tools out
there that can help you become an aipim
like you might be familiar with mid
journey and Dolly from open AI but these
are paid close Source Products that also
contain a bunch of unwanted safety
layers luckily there's a great open
source ecosystem around generative AI
the most well-known base model is stable
diffusion XL which was released in Late
July 2023 gigantic models like this take
an absurd amount of computing power but
luckily it's possible to fine-tune them
by creating what's called a checkpoint
using some additional specialized
training data now you don't have to
worry about this part because people
have already created a bunch of
different checkpoints which you can find
on websites like civit AI some of which
are highly optimized for photo realism
now the next part of the puzzle is
finding a UI where we can actually work
with these models without having to
write any code the most well-known
option is the stable diffus Fusion web
UI it's an incredibly powerful tool but
might be a little overwhelming for a
beginner there's just a lot of different
buttons to push another cool option is
comfy UI which has a drag and drop
editor that works kind of like blender
or Unreal Engine but the one I'm using
in this video is focus or fucus and I'll
explain why I like it in just a minute
you'll notice all these AI uis look very
similar and that's because they're based
on another open source project called
gradio and an interesting side note is
that gradio builds the front end with
spelt pretty cool but let's get started
check out the install instructions but
basically all you do is clone the repo
create a virtual environment for Python
and install the packages once that's
done you run this python script which
will then automatically download the
default models in the background these
files are multiple gigabytes large so it
may take a while the base model is
Juggernaut XL which is based on stable
diffusion and works pretty well for
realistic images you now have the power
at your fingertips to PRT out any image
you can imagine the thing I like about
focus is that in many ways it feels
similar to mid-journey but it's free and
the UI is way more intuitive I'm running
it with a modest Nvidia 370 and it
usually takes takes about 45 seconds to
generate two quality images what's
really cool though is that if you click
on the advanced tab you'll get options
for performance aspect ratio and the
number of images but there's also a tab
for style and we can mix and match these
different styles to get far different
results like this retro video game style
or maybe an anime style but in order to
generate our AI influencer I'm going to
go with the default settings along with
Focus photograph create a prompt that's
highly specific and add some
imperfections like rough skin no makeup
Etc to make it more realistic and now
our influencer is Bor now let's go ahead
and save this as our base image then
create a new prompt and check the box
for input image Drop the Base image here
to blend multiple images and text
together now click on the Advan box
below the image so you find tune the way
the image is Blended in this case we'll
go with face swap and then write a text
prompt of doing yoga at the beach giving
us that perfect shot for the gram but
most importantly we have pretty good
continuity between the faces and the
hands almost look totally realistic but
when you have imperfections you can go
back to the image prompt but this time
go to in paint or out paint and then
paint across the parts that are messed
up tell it what you want to fix then it
will regenerate those parts of the image
congratulations you just built your own
artificial influencer you did it but
photos are only the beginning yesterday
pabs released an insane video demoing
their text to video platform it's closed
Source but luckily stability AI just
introduced stable diffusion video last
week and I can only imagine what kind of
depraved content you guys will use that
for this has been the code report thanks
for watching and I will see you in the
next one